hello in the last video you learnt about
hierarchical clustering in this video
you are going to learn about k means
clustering method
so we are going to use the same data set
with the 52 samples and approximately 6
900 genes that we will create the simple
pipeline in the unsupervised learning
section of the tbi info platform
navigate to the unsupervised learning
area under data mining and upload
the file as before
then create your pipeline
as we are going to discuss
first of all you need to click on the
start module
click ok
and now you need to click on the k means
module
now let's see what should be the values
of the parameters
for the number of iterations say 10 000
for clusters expected count set a value
of 5 and for dou transpose set to true
means that we cluster samples
false would lead to clustering features
that is in our case of genes
give your pipeline an original
undescriptive name and then run the
pipeline as before you may click on my
pipelines and periodically check the
status of your pipeline
this is a fast pipeline so it should
finish quickly after the pipeline has
finished clicking on the name of your
pipeline will bring you to a list of
folders
key means does not have a visual output
so let's take a look at the table of
samples with the cluster assigned to
each sample
clusters table only will have the result
in a tabular format
to quickly check whether the output
corresponds to known cancer subtypes we
can add the subtype labels to each
sample name and sort the table by
cluster id
now to interpret your result in the
tabular format you can refer to lesson
13 of transcriptomics on the omixlogic
portal